[Musique]
bienvenue en débat sur france 24
consacrait un rapport de l'onu accablant
sur la politique de pékin à l'égard des
ouïghours l'organisation évoque des
crimes contre l'humanité qui pourrait
avoir été commis dans la région du sine
chang michelle bachelet la haute
commissaire aux droits de l'homme a
publié ses 46 pages quelques minutes
avant la fin de son mandat le rapport
est fondé sur des écrits et déclarations
des autorités chinoises mais aussi sur
le travail de chercheurs des images
satellites sur quarante entretiens dont
vingt-six personnes ayant été internés
ou ayant travaillé dans des camps un
outil politique rédigé par des sbires
des occidentaux a réagi la chine
l'allemagne a appelé le gouvernement
chinois à accorder immédiatement à tous
les habitants du think tank le plein
exercice de leurs droits humains alors
on va bien sûr revenir ce soir sur ce
rapport pourquoi michelle bachelet la
haute commissaire des droits de l'homme
l'at-elle publiés si tard quelle est la
responsabilité de ces jingping dans la
persécution des ouigours quel est
l'impact de ce rapport alors que les
tensions montent entre la chine et les
états unis et que les réactions se sont
multipliées en europe on en parle avec
mes invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à
mes côtés deal n'eurent real bonsoir
vous êtes présidente de l'institut
ouigours d'europe bienvenue dans le
débat merci à vous d'être là en face de
vous et jean-paul chang bon soir vous
êtes économiste cofondateur de la lettre
de chine bienvenue à vous à côté de vous
alain de chalvron bonsoir alain grand
reporter ancien correspondant de france
télévisions en asie en particulier avec
nos également jean françois di miglio
bonsoir président de léger center
professeur à l'université paris dauphine
et à la public schools internationales
faire offre sérieuse bienvenue à vous un
mélange d'entretien donc réalisé par les
nations unies on évoque un crime contre
l'humanité jean françois di meglio pour
cadrer ce débat qu'est ce qu'apporte ce
rapport alors que à certains nombres de
ng l et même plus loin puisqu'il parlait
de génocide aux états unis on parle de
génocide la l'onu donc évoque un crime
contre l'humanité il apporte une sorte
d'autorité que vous l'avez dit
puisque effectivement c'est un rapport
de l'onu on avait eu jusqu'à présent
dans nos mémoires ce qui est le plus
fort c'est les positions du parlement
européen si vous vous en souvenez donc
en début 2021 une action qui avait eu un
certain nombre de conséquences puisque
c'était le moment où la chine était en
train de négocier avec les européens le
fameux cros agreements and investment et
on avait mis un terme aux négociations
et à certains noms de personnalités
individuelles dont raphaël glucksmann
députés européens mais aussi des
institutions y compris des think-tanks
est un think tank allemand merricks
mercator institute avait été sanctionné
par la chine à l'époque c'était la
première fois que la chine faisait d'une
certaine façon preuve
d'extraterritorialité si on peut appeler
ça ainsi dans les mesures qu'elle
prenait contre des étrangers et malgré
ça l'onu est nécessaire ce rapport en
tout cas à porte voilà le l'onu est une
autorité en théorie indiscutable est ce
que ça nous apporte aussi c'est la
contestation par une puissance
multilatérale qui va siéger à
l'assemblée générale de l'onu la semaine
prochaine
d'un rapport rédigé par l'onu comment
est ce que les représentants de la chine
vont ils se comporter lorsqu'ils seront
à l'assemblée générale la semaine
prochaine dinard et alors il n'y a pas
de chiffre officiel est évoqué par l'onu
ce sur le nombre de détenus ouïghours il
dit simplement qu'il est très important
il parle de entre 10 à 20% de la
population adulte qui aurait été au
moins à un moment ou un autre détenu
dans des camps à selon donc les
chercheurs de l'onu quel est votre avis
sur ce rapport à ce qu'il va assez loin
vous en tant qu'association vous parlez
d'un million de wii gourdan les quand
nous parlons en fait en tant que
chercheuse que je lui parle et non pas
en tant que représentant d'une
association les chercheurs on estime à
environ 3 millions de personnes qui sont
internés dans des camps et prison 3
millions bout de trois millions environ
et qu' il faut savoir que en fait ce
sont des structures différentes il n'y a
pas que camps d'internement dans deux
camps de concentration mais il y a aussi
les camps de travail mais aussi en fait
les prisons mais quand ils sont
transformés de plus en plus en prison
aussi donc on en remet ce rapport en
effet nous apprend rien de nouveau et
que tu n'as les ong et les chercheurs et
les investigateurs notamment les
journalistes il avait déjà révélé mais
enfin comme comme ça vient d'âtre est
évoquée effectivement venu en tant que
structure internationale incontestable
en théorie est que cette ce rapport est
quand même important important parce que
elle a l'autorité l'onu à ce que vous
rejoignez ce que vient de dire jean
françaix di meglio jean paul chang oui
si vous êtes d'accord avec ce que vient
d'être dit sur l'autorité de l'onu sont
finalement qu'elle apporte tout de même
une pierre à l'édifice dans justement la
mise en accusation de pékin dans la
répression des ouigours alors j'ai
quelques doutes c'est évidemment sur
l'importance que pékin va accorder à
cette autorité je pense que pékin a déjà
traité le rapport de force
tenir à des sbires occidentaux oui voilà
donc peco fait remarquer que tous les
témoignages qui sont recueillis dans ce
rapport ont déjà fait l'objet de
réputation et ils ont exigé
effectivement que le haut-commissariat
publie le rapport certes mais que soit
immédiatement suivi par le rapport de
réputation qui fait à peu près 150 pages
où ils reviennent évidemment sur tous
les cas les interviews d orange et les
mensonges entre guillemets bon voilà
donc je pense qu'il réfute mais ce qu'il
est utile c'est le rapport c'est
sûrement utile pour ceux qui veulent eux
mené un peu la campagne pour les droits
de l'homme en chine et évidemment du
panneau chinois bon bah ça cristallise
finalement il certaines pensions en
train ça va mon pays occidentaux riz la
chine puisque ça va être servi
évidemment comme comme instrument de
l'aube devant l'affrontement idéologique
entre le monde occidental si je sais
dire et puis la chine de l'autre côté ça
va accroître encore les tensions alain
tien liong qui pensent que je sceau des
nations unies important ça va pas calmer
les temps sur un chat c'est sûr mais
ce que je dirais surtout c'est que c'est
une grosse défaite pour le régime
chinois c'est une grosse défaite d'abord
parce que le contenu de ce rapport est
quand même accablant qu'il va circuler
dans le monde entier puisque c'est l'onu
qui l'a 7 ce tampon onusien qui rend la
le document incontestable quelque part
et les chinois quoi qu'on en dise ils
sont assez soucieux de l'image qu'ils
donnent donc vous n'êtes pas d'accord
avec jean paul chang je suis plus plus
catégorique que lui oui et c'est une
défaite aussi parce que depuis dix ans
même peut-être un peu plus la chine très
intelligemment et très méthodiquement à
noyauter le système des nations unies en
plaçant des gens à droite à gauche et là
c'est une quand même c'est une gifle et
je plains pour vous dire la vérité
l'ambassadeur chinois à genève qui à mon
avis aura des problèmes sont près de
chez vous pouvez réagir vous le plaignez
aussi cet ambassadeur il va s'avérer
compliqué aujourd'hui dans une certaine
mesure je suis d'accord avec ce que vous
en ai dit ça se voit que bien entendu
c'est un échec diplomatique en apparence
mais j'en apparences en apparence parce
qu'effectivement ça ne va pas beaucoup
d'effet à vrai dire sur la conduite des
affaires par la chine dans cette région
quant au fond c'est ça que je veux dire
quand elle a quant à l'existence d'une
d'une dune de tête en fait d'une
utilisation du thème lutte de deux du
shin tian comme d'ailleurs le thème du
tibet au de hong kong taiwan par les
occidentaux dans leur opposition
frontale aujourd'hui avec la chine là
des chinois s'y attendent depuis
longtemps donc ce n'est pas un échec non
plus
ressenti tel quel donc vous dites c'est
pas vraiment nouveau jean françois di
meglio pourquoi michelle bachelet at
elle attendu si longtemps est ce que les
chinois ont effectivement exercé une
grosse pression on on peut l'imaginer on
peut l'imaginer effectivement
ensuite
ce
les éléments effectivement été étaient
réunis depuis depuis longtemps c'est
depuis 2010 800 le son mandat a commencé
pratiquement en 2018 depuis le début de
son mandat les éléments et les éléments
étaient acculés elle a fait cette
mission cette mission et mais hélas mois
des nations au mois de mai et donc il
fallait quand même pour parer les
contradictions auxquelles on pouvait
s'attendre il fallait nécessairement
qu'elle qu'elle exécute cette mission
mais rappelez vous quand elle est
revenue de cette mission on a tous
étaient sidérés par le commentaire
personnel de michelle bachelet sur ce
qu'elle avait vu ce qu'elle a mis en
évidence des points positifs on s'est
demandé ce qu'elle avait vu aussi le
tient pour dire des choses pareilles
alors justement on va l'écouter parce
qu'on a retrouvé ce qu'elle a pu dire
c'était le 25 août à genève donc c'était
quelques mois après cette cette mission
les coûts de michelle bachelet
comme un pin up et j'étais sous pression
nous avons toujours été sous pression et
de tous les côtés et dans toutes les
situations je dirais pas seulement des
membres des ong mais aussi de la société
civile pas notre travail est guidé par
les droits humains et par les faits sur
le terrain et leur analyse objective
des scanners dans le cas de ce rapport
j'ai été soumise à d'énormes pressions
pour la publier ou ne pas le publier
mais ce ne sont pas ces pressions qui
feront que je le publie que je renonce à
sa publication
elle a littéralement publié quatre
heures après la fin de son aile quatre
heures avant la montre on en a juste
avant la fin de son mandat c'est tout de
même quelque chose d'assez inédit vue mi
temps vit bien je suis parmi minutes
avant vous pensez qu'elle ne pas
n'avaient pas la publier oui si on avait
perdu l'espoir en effet
finalement ça a été fait a publié dix
minutes avant tant mieux pour elles
parce qu'elles avaient totalement gâché
son mandat mais aussi gâchis sur sa
réputation
sauf un type e au minimum son honneur à
sauver son honneur en tout cas la
réaction qu'évidemment de pékin ne s'est
pas fait attendre juste après la
publication de ce rapport on va écouter
le porte parole du ministère des
affaires étrangères chinois
la soi-disant évaluation que vous avez
mentionné est orchestrée et fabriqué par
les états unis et certaines puissances
occidentales elle est totalement
illégale et invalide ce rapport est un
ramassis nos fausses informations qui
sert d'outil politique aux etats-unis et
à l'occident pour utiliser
stratégiquement le xinjiang afin de
contenir la chine n'ont pas de chance
c'est ce que vous disiez donc en fait
ils parlent d' instrumentalisation de
fabrication tout simplement moi
j'entends côté d'occident j'essaie
d'interpréter répulsion chinoise donc
effectivement il confirme ce que de mon
analyse là dessus ce que je veux dire
c'est que les les les chinois dans leurs
réponses par rapport à ce document de
l'onu
avancent le fait qu' ils n'ont pas la
même conception des droits de l'homme
quelque part donc discutent ils
disputent même la notion de droits de
l'homme tel qu'avancé par
le haut commissariat en disant que pour
nous le droit fondamental de l'homme
c'est de pouvoir vivre en paix et que le
fait qu'ils aient réussi à mettre fin au
terrorisme au séparatisme nouveaux
troubles et pour que les gens du
xinkiang puissent bénéficier d'un
développement et de sortir la pauvreté
pour eux c'est ça le droit de l'homme
que eux ils ont accompli donc quelque
part on comprend que eux ils se mettent
dans leur droit moral pour contester les
conclusions de ce rapport qui est par
ailleurs comme vous dites accablant
diminuera votre votre réaction justement
à ce que dit la chine
ce n'est pas une surprise la réaction de
la chine et que depuis le début la chine
a toujours nié les crimes qu'elle a
commis et que si vous vous souvenez
jusqu'en octobre 2018 la chine elle elle
nie totalement l'existence des camps et
après face aux preuves finalement elle a
dû reconnaître ensuite de justifier
pourquoi évidemment en fait comme dans
un monde aux islamophobes a aujourd'hui
est que pour la chine c'était le bon
moment de justifier tous tous ces crimes
ou non de au nom de la lutte contre le
terrorisme en plus de cela machine elle
même elle justifie en disant que est en
fait tous ces personnes qui sont qu'ils
ont internet ils n'ont commis aucun
crime cependant machine qui estime que
peut-être dans le futur ils vont
commettre donc se sont ils expliquent
centre de prévention centre prévention
justement à un chevron les ouigours
c'est pour revenir justement un peu sûrs
qu'ils sont sont des musulmans sunnites
je parle sous votre contrôle la plupart
parlent donc une langue proche du turc
en fait ils sont environ 12 millions
dans cette province mais manifestement
ils étaient beaucoup plus nombreux
d'ailleurs avant 1949
comment est-ce qu'on peut les placer
est-ce que c'est stratégique pour la
chine justement cette région du xinjiang
historiquement parlant ça a toujours été
une région tampon entre la chine
chinoise et l'asie centrale musulmane
depuis toujours il ya une très brève
période d'indépendance de la région mais
à part ça ça toujours été plus ou moins
plus ou moins directement contrôlée par
la chine alors aujourd'hui pourquoi est
ce que c'est si si important pour le
régime de pékin parce que enfin le
détonateur c'est tout de même été des
attentats terroristes qui a eu et en
particulier un attentat qui a eu lieu
devant la le portrait de mao sur la
place tiananmen et ça c'est perdre la
face perdre la face pour les chinois
c'est ce qu'il ya de pire et donc ils se
sont jurés ya eu d'autres attentats
assez sanglant aussi à urumqi chine et
dans le dans la région de kunming à la
gare de kunming et donc c'est ça le
nouveau pouvoir six jeunes pillards et
teasing donc a décidé de taper très fort
et c'est ce qui se passe en ce moment
c'est ce qui s'est passé vous êtes
d'accord non je ne suis absolument pas
d'accord avec cette théorie qui la
reprise partout en effet et que sa jupe
dans le comment dire effectivement dans
la propagande chinoise aussi qui est qui
et qui justifie par la sa politique en
réalité il faut savoir que en fait c'est
comment dire la région est lourde elle
et c'est une colonie chinoise et
notamment l'économie chinoise depuis
1949 avant cela qui était une république
indépendante mais relativement
indépendant disons cette même si c'est
un mythe c'était un état satellite et
que depuis 1949 la chine exerce dans la
région une politique coloniale et que
dans cette politique coloniale
évidemment il ya mécontentement personne
aucun aucun peuple ne mérite la
colonisation par un autre peuple et que
dans cette dans ce contexte ans il ya eu
toujours de contestation mais depuis et
à comment amener le but de la chine et
des dirigeants chinois depuis toujours
c'était à coop accaparé le territoire
ouïghours totalement il fallait mener
excuses un prétexte pour se lie depuis
2002 quel est ce prétexte le prétexte
c'est bien entendu après la commande et
11 septembre 2001 c'est la lutte
internationale contre le terrorisme qui
est bien exercée par la chine sur ce
prétexte tout la police politique toute
la population ouïghoure a été placé
comme en fait une population à séparer
ségrégué à dangereux et donc finalement
à éradiquer alors justement
jean françois di miglio madame reillanne
parle justement de cette politique de
colonisation mais pourquoi est ce que si
jean ping parce que manifestement on
voit bien que c'est lui même qui a durci
pourquoi est il durcit cette répression
à l'égard des ouïghours en particulier
je pense qu'il ya plusieurs niveaux à la
fois dans ce qu'on a entendu du porte
parole et puis aussi ce commentaire qui
est tout à fait justifiée sur les
motivations effectivement dû du peuple
ouïghour bon il est clair que les
motivations du peuple ouïghour d'un
point de vue international elles ne sont
pas reconnues aujourd'hui les frontières
de la chine d'un point de vue
international inclut le territoire we go
mais cette montée en puissance en fait
elle fait suite probablement à la
reconnaissance d'une forme d'échec qui
était la colonisation au sens où vous
l'avez indiqué c'est à dire là le pop le
mans du soutien par des populations
crâne le peuplement d'époque du cydia ou
par des populations donc chinoise par
l'envoi de fonctionnaires par l'envoi de
deux personnes en poste au xinjiang
étaient destinés à progressivement
incorporé comme la chine le fait très
souvent ce territoire dans une grande
zone de culture chinoise ça n'a pas
marché et donc effectivement on monte
d'un cran et puis il ya une autre
dimension celle qu'on constate avec le
le porte-parole mais c'est cette
incertitude chinoise qui elle aussi a
deux aspects le fait de dire on sort du
jeu international c'est quand même
quelque chose d'énorme
entendre un rapport de l'onu et le
traiter comme un chiffon de papier
ça veut dire quand même on a une autre
proposition de gouvernance
internationale qui peut être meilleure
que celle que l'onu nous propose et ça
c'est très important et c'est pour ça
que effectivement les échéances qui sont
devant nous vous être un test pour cette
tentative de nouvelle gouvernance on
sent bien que la chine ait envie de ça
mais d'un autre côté cette gouvernance
la chine voit bien qu'elle est
terriblement menacé y compris par ceux
qui pourraient être ses amis
l'invasion de l'ukraine ça va pas
vraiment dans le sens de la gouvernance
sinoise
promotrice de la paix et là je pense la
chine a été assez surprise de ça mais
elle se sent cerner pour autant elle n'a
pas envie d'aller vers la russie mais
elle se sent cerner parking pardonnez
moi c'est org c'est une obsession
chinoise rappelez vous que ça veut dire
le territoire non pas du milieu comme le
centre de la terre mais celui qui est
cernée par tous les autres il est cerné
et si vous reprenez les cartes ou les
représentations historiques y compris
par un grand penseur du dudule parti
communiste
il ya plusieurs cercles autour du centre
chinois et ce sont des cercles de
barbares plus ou moins civilisés et plus
on va loin plus on a des barbares et
donc et ses valises et les garants il
met à cette répression et oui parce
qu'il se sent encore une fois emma
l'usman avec moyens on dit si de plus en
plus isolé ce qui est peut-être pas
totalement faux mais ce à quoi ils
contribuent très fortement et
effectivement avec un objectif qui
semble le plus en plus des douaniers de
la réalité jean-paul sûrement plus il ya
donc à le fait normalement ils devraient
le mandat devrait être donc et bien
renfort faf renforcer en tout cas il
devrait être à nouveau élu si je puis
dire par le parti communiste puisqu'il
est le seul à l'union donc un rôle dans
le concret 14 octobre mais pour revenir
simplement sur l'origine du problème
mais pourquoi tshimpi nouveaux cas s'ils
sont tous sous sa présidence il faut
quand même voir quand même que l'on peut
pas totalement niés qui a eu quand même
une influence du djihad sur une partie
de la population ouïghoure et où on a
trouvé des djihadistes ouïghours en
syrie et ailleurs qui sont à l'intérieur
de l'état islamique aussi donc dire que
que la répression a été plus aveugle et
plus générale sur la population
ouïghoure c'est une chose et mme aigner
totalement le fait qu'ils aient des
attentats des morts jusqu'à chrome ming
qui est quand même le sud la chine ou
sur place herman c'est pas une question
de perdre la face et perdre des vies
parce que quand même en plein jour à au
moutchic des émeutes et qui a 150 morts
c'est s'il est commis par les ouigours
oui entre autres et c'était c'était une
cité batave quant
à peu près sûr sur l'outil donc les
joueurs vous ne pouvez pas n'importe
quel gouvernement ne peut pas ne pas
réagir à ça et donc à partir de là si
vous voulez compte tenu de la nature du
régime ce genre si tu permets à temps
mais nous avons réagi au bataclan le
l'occident a réagi au bataclan mais avec
des mesures légèrement différente de
celle que la chine appliqué c'est ce que
j'avais dit à mon cher compte tenu de la
nature des régions chinois tu pouvais
pas attendre à autre chose que des
mesures qui sont plus autre chose en
signori terre c'est ça que je veux dire
mais il est clair que le régime il fait
pas il fait il faisait face quand même à
des rêves risque de séparation et dotés
de deux théories jeu juste en face sur
cette question le terrorisme n'est qu'un
prétexte par le gouvernement chinois
ensuite ce que vous soulignez comme en
fait ceux qui sont commandés retrouver
des ouigours combattants en ciré ce sont
je vous rappelle que c'est en 2015 et
que en 2015 de entre 2014 2015 environ
1000 ouïghours ont été portés par les
autorités chinoises par la chine ce sont
des ruraux qui n'ont ni passeport ni vu
ni la langue ils s'en sortent et non pas
de notre coût de nos frontières
habituelles juste à côté de nous en asie
centrale mais ils ont traversé toute la
chine un autre continent pour aller
avoue vite n'en est que ce qui en fait
vous savez qu'on nous juge est grande et
dans comment dire dans cette région l'a
ensuite j'ai famiz études en chine et
que en tant que ouigours je sais qu elle
de contrôle au faciès est extrêmement
sévère et que en fait ce sont le lisent
des attentats d'ailleurs ceux-ci trois
attentats que trouvent et les chinois et
le comment dire souligne souvent ce sont
en fait en réalité ces décès sont des
accusations chinoise ils n'y ont aucune
enquête indépendante a été réalisée ont
été réalisés et aussi ensuite en fait
connaissant comment les gars comment les
centres sens nous contrôler lorsqu en
fait il ya un seul ouïghours est présent
et d'immédiatement la police qui vient
lorsque nous arrive quand on fait de
l'humour en france ou ailleurs on rentre
en fait dans notre dans notre pays on
passe par pékin dès notre arrivée la
nuit la police entre débarque
d'angleterre pour nous faillir et que
ben avoir ce type d'attentât par les
ouïghours librement comme ça on parle
alors que pendant une demi heure la
police ne vient pas c'est juste
impossible
oui je suis d'accord que les et les
attentats ont été utilisée comme
prétexte pour une répression la chose la
plus grave peut-être vu de pékin c'est
ce qui s'est passé en 2010 des
affrontements entre ouïghours et chinois
he and how rouchy dans la capitale là à
pékin on s'est dit ça va mal il faut
faire quelque chose ce que je voudrais à
jouer donc la répression c'était l'arrêt
de la récession mais c'est pas le ce
régime là à l'époque c'était jintao
s'est donc c'est jean ping quelques
années plus tard donc je voudrais juste
ajouter une chose c'est pas un truc
isolé ce qui se passe chez les we go
c'est une politique de sinisation à
marche forcée qu'à décider si jean ping
et qu'on retrouve même sur des musulmans
qui sont tout à fait chinois qui sont
ran mais qui n'ont plus le droit
d'écrire ans avec des caractères arabes
dont on a démoli les minarets etc c'est
vrai aussi pour les mongols c'est vrai
pour les tibétains etc y ait volonté de
signer sinisation de tout l'ensemble
chinois qui est clair et d'une certaine
manière un durcissement terrible y
compris pour les chinois
la vie en chine a beaucoup changé et
elle est de plus en plus dur et pourquoi
jean françois di meglio encore aaron va
reparler des réactions internationales
pourquoi encore une fois estime jean
ping est il devenu aussi répressif aussi
dur effectivement c'est ce qui sera
nécessaire d'appeler cette assertivité à
deux visages c'est à dire 'c'est ta
certifie tai chi est clairement le fait
que pendant des années est la chine a
tout gagné donc effectivement les
objectifs d'un régime comme le régime
chinois ont été atteints du point de vue
international avec la négociation de
grands traités commerciaux avec une
certaine forme de reconnaissance avec
comme ça a été rappelé très justement la
présence tout à fait légitime quand on
voit le rendre la chine dans le jeu
multilatéral deux représentants chinois
dans les organismes internationaux tout
à fait légitime donc la chine était en
train de tout gagner cette victoire a
conduit à une forme de ce qu'on appelle
en anglais de certifier c'est
l'affirmation de soi c'est ça qui
effectivement justifier en partie mais
c'est un certificat qui le crée une
forme d'autonomie mégalomanie oui alors
je ne dirais pas ça c'est que cet accès
l'activité aurait dû avoir des
conséquences c'est-à-dire
une relative bienveillance ou une
acceptation par le monde extérieur de
cette assertivité et pour toutes sortes
de raisons que la chine a tendance à
considérer comme mauvaise cette
incertitude et n'est pas bien reçue par
le monde extérieur alors à nous de juger
si c'est a certifié thx et bienvenue ou
pas bienvenu mais en tout cas il est
clair que la répression n'est pas
bienvenu pour le monde extérieur en
l'occurrence pour les démocraties à des
panneaux m ça ne fait pas partie des
valeurs démocratiques ensuite puisqu'il
s'agit de nu quand même il faut voir
aussi ce qui peut se passer dans une
assemblée générale parce que du point de
vue des populations
l'acce la totalité des populations qui
sont tentés soit s'abstenir soit voter
dans le même sens que la chine en terme
de population un dirigeant chinois vous
dira nous représentants plus d'humains
que ce que votre monde occidental
représente et la grande injustice aux
yeux d'un dirigeant chignon bas c'est
que en termes de jours et bien c'est une
paix un pays une voix et donc dans une
assemblée générale on pourra vous
contestez un jour le principe même de la
démocratie à l'onu un accès
international en tout cas on en parlait
avec l'allemagne qui a appelé le
gouvernement chinois à accorder
immédiatement je cite à tous les
habitants de sin kiang le plein exercice
de leurs droits humains josette borel le
chef de la diplomatie européenne
condamne on va écouter sa porte parole
you're strange les copains union
européenne condamne fermement les
violations des droits humains au
signifiant et dans d'autres parties de
la chine en particulier la persécution
des ouigours et d'autres personnes
appartenant à des minorités religieuses
ou ethniques
je soulève la question du cygne shiang
avec les autorités chinoises depuis des
années un forum spécifique
dit ne rien comment les européens
devraient ils réagir aujourd'hui il
condamne mais à ce qu'il devrait par
exemple mettre en place un certain
nombre de sanctions ont parlement
européen on en a beaucoup parlé en
l'occurrence de contrôler vous parliez
de raphaël glucksmann de contrôler les
filières dans lesquelles les filières
par exemple dans le textile dans
lesquels qui font appel aux ouigours qui
sont dans dans ces camps est ce que il
faut en passer par là on parle de la
depuis la guerre un magnet par la russie
contre l'ukraine et la russie riquet
isolé sur la scène internationale
notamment par leur passé l'europe amener
à adopter une série de mesures de
sanction sévère contre la russie est que
tandis que pendant que pendant que en
fait on nous reconnaissons même ici à
l'assemblée nationale française une un
génocide qui en cours menée par la chine
et on fait toujours pas grand-chose
parle pour qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
faire et que la laune l'europe le
rapport de l'onu au moins le mérite
maintenant de pousser les saisies
démocratie en tout cas si pays dit
démocratique à
soumettre la chine désormais and
en cour internationale pour que la chine
rendu qu'on rende compte rendre des
comptes pour ces crimes est ce que par
exemple aujourd'hui avec ce rapport les
ong par exemple qui est représentée we
go à ce qu'elles peuvent saisir
aujourd'hui la cour de justice avec ce
rapport les originaux puisque les ong
ont déjà tenté sans effet puisque enfin
c'est comment dire la cour
internationale de la haye notamment est
contrôlé par la chine et que notamment
enfin le comment il le conseil de
sécurité de l'onu est aussi sous emprise
de de la chine
et de la russie et que dans cet effet là
les origines on ne peut pas c'est
pourquoi en fait il faudrait que
désormais à ces démocraties de le faire
de faire donc justement quel titre de
sanction à skis c'est à l'anci allemand
est ce que c'est la bonne approche celle
de sanctions de la part de pays
européens justement contre un certain
nombre peut-être de produits qui sont
reproduits par eweek bourg
difficile à dire or les sanctions sont
rarement très efficace un surtout quand
elles sont très parcellaires comme ça si
on en face en général toute la chesnaie
qu'on décide qu'on apportera plus rien
de chine oui ça peut avoir de les films
ça sera en calcin pas sur le coton un
certain nombre de matières premières de
production de la région des ouigours ça
changera pas le cours des choses
franchement alors qu'est ce que peuvent
faire les payer vous savez maintenant
dans cette histoire des ouigours c'est
que personne n'y a pas de pays de la
région de pays musulmans en particulier
ou arabe qui est prêt pas position pour
les wings ils sont abandonnés alors il
ya eu quelques interventions du
kazakhstan parce qu'on parle des
ouigours mais il ya aussi les kazakhs et
d'une minorité de la même région ils
sont 7% il ya eu des interventions
ponctuelles et personnel mais sinon
personne ne moufte
les européens en fait il devrait faire
quelque chose bloquer l'accord
qui a été lui aussi pendant huit ans sur
les investissements réciproques entre
nos mains est ce qu'elle est réellement
bloqué cet accord
le mans opus de le parlement qui est
très en pointe sur ces questions
d'ouïghours avec un vrai luxe mais non
tout on a parlé effectivement ça bloque
ça bloque complètement de la crise celle
ci étant dit ça n'empêche pas les
accords entre l'allemagne et la chine
sur l'automobile par exemple ou alors
c'est un accord sur les investissements
donc c'est autre chose c'est un accord
qui avait énormément de pertinence tant
que la chine pendant ses huit ans avait
les moyens si j'ose dire d'investir à
l'extérieur la situation économique
chinoise ne pousse plus tellement à
encourager les investissements à
l'extérieur donc là encore une fois on
peut se poser la question si même avec
la suppression de cet accord d'une
certaine façon la chine n'est pas
gagnante à la fin du jeu puisque il
intéresse peut-être beaucoup moins qu'il
aurait pu intéresser les européens qui
eux ont souhaité investir plus en chine
parce qu'effectivement la chine far est
amoureux est maire de l'europe la chine
économiquement c'est bien sûr
un partenaire puisqu'on est le deuxième
ou le troisième partenaire et la chine
est le premier partenaire de l'europe et
de la plupart de la plupart des pays
c'est peut-être ça qui va être remis en
cause par un certain nombre de facteurs
qui sont en train d'avoir lieu c'est
ainsi il à l'initiative on parlait
surtout d'initiative officielles
gouvernementales européennes
multilatérale mais la question qu'on se
pose aujourd'hui y compris dans les
patronats européens c est ce qu on a pas
mis trop de billets en chine donc on se
retire de chine ça ça ferait une hôtesse
retirer de chine du jour au lendemain
parce que vous avez une valeur de marché
qui est lié à la valeur de ce que vous
avez investi en chine et on peut pas
passer à 0 les investissements qu'on a
fait en revanche on a un moyen comme on
dit en anglais de couvrir ces paris et
pour un dollar qui a été investi en
chine un jour eh bien allez investir 1
dollar et demi ailleurs et
progressivement repondéré le poids des
investissements en chine sans pour
autant se retirer de chine et attendre
aussi il faut qu'on le mentionne des
jours meilleurs parce que des personnes
comme jean-paul comme comme alain est
comme moi nous avons le privilège de
suivre la chine depuis très longtemps et
donc nous savons que la chine va par
cycle aussi est ce à la sig jean ping il
est là pour longtemps manie facilement
il a modifié ses voeux la constitution
il va rester on a effectivement un 20e
congrès qui ne va pas le déclarer leader
avis qui va simplement lui donner un
troisième mandat ce qui ne s'est pas vu
précédemment mais les mandats sont les
mandats la vie politique même en chine
et la vie politique est ce qui
caractérise l'histoire chinoise depuis
4000 ans ce sont les cycles et le sict y
suit le cycle précédent souvent celle
inverse du cycle auquel on succède à
vraiment vous y croyez des murs et abat
cette théorie des cycles je pense que le
but jean ping s'est justement en finir
avec les ouigours et avec le taiwan
aussi donc si en face dans le troisième
mandat qui sera accordé et que tu le dis
aussi par la suite on le on ne sait pas
encore et puis également il ya un peuple
est en train d'être éradiquée il y a en
fait rien ne le crient leur rapport de
l'onu cette fois qui dit crimes contre
l'humanité il ya en fait du moins sans
parler de génocide il y en a qui encourt
toujours depuis cinq ans il ya un crime
contre l'humanité et fait contre un
peuple et que nous en discutons de en
fait un jour meilleur vous en faites
comment dire comme gens posent là
mentionné comment dire il commande et
instrumentalisations on parle d'
instrumentalisation de ce rapport il ya
un peuple est en train d'être éradiquée
en attendant quoi en attendant peut-être
comme un choix totalement que la chine
et shipping puisse finir avec ce qu'elle
a commencé et ensuite pour arriver pour
dire on our a dû voilà c'est ça la
question qui doit supposer qu'il ya un
peuple est en train d'être éradiquée
moi je suis un peu plus en retrait par
rapport à l'expression utilisée ce comme
hmm hmm le rapport si vous lisez de près
mais tout le monde s'en fiche un peu de
gens qui vont lire le rapport je vous
assure moi je me suis tapé le rapport a
jusqu'à z et que c'est seulement dans
l'avant-dernier paragraphe on demande
aux gens de faire attention dans les
importations des produits qui sont liées
adhérer à des régions où il ya des
problèmes de vibrations de l'homme et
qu'en tant qu'ancien concerne de la
mention de crimes contre l'humanité si
au conditionnel si au conditionnel donc
ce que je voulais dire c'est que ce
qui se passe c'est que si tim ping pour
son troisième mandat c'était une chose
je pense effectivement moi je crois vrai
non plus à mon avis médical chine pierre
a comme but aujourd'hui d'éradiquer les
ouigours je pensais vraiment très
excessif parce que c'est ce que c'est ce
que vous dites
en fait je m'en tiens juste en fait
comment dire là selon la star du show la
stérilisation massive des femmes
ouïghours qui fait qu entre temps toute
la région entre 2010 et 2019 en deux ans
la chute démographique ses 55% et que
rien que pour les deux préfectures les
plus importants bretagne cash car
c'était cette chute concerne 84 % c'est
pourquoi les chercheurs
or la du génocide
savons oui génocide si on pense on ce
qui s'est passé dans l'histoire du monde
au 20ème siècle non c'est pas un
génocide on ne tue pas tous les ouigours
on l'est on peut pas signer ce n'est pas
une définition du génocide je vous
invite à regarder la définition
juridique de dieu vienne aussi il n'ya
pas de mention en fait il ya cinq
critères et il y avait enfin un seul
critère suffit pour être qualifié 2e et
vous m'avez pas laisser terminer en
revanche je pense qu'on peut parler de
génocide culturel oui c'est vrai il ya
aussi des stérilisations de femmes pour
limiter la population ouïghoure même si
on ne les tue pas mais en revanche la
religion l'écriture la culture les
traditions et sert à tout ça il ya une
volonté d'éradication on veut empêcher
les jeunes ouïghours de parler autre
chose que le chinois que le mandarin
donc il ya un vrai génocide culturel
mais je dirais pas même si j'ai en fait
la définition souligne juste en fait
nous avons en fait publier un
commentaire les chercheurs et les
chercheurs dans différents domaines
c'est à dire d'études ouïghours d'études
chinoises d'étude du génocide
alors il de crimes internationaux nous
avons publié en juillet un article quand
comment acquis intitulé un consensus
scientifique sur les jeunes séduits
lourd et que giuly se lit aussi sur la
question de définition du génocide
socialisation massive c'est un critère
pour être qualifiés de génocide
en tout cas l'onu parle donc un de
crimes contre l'humanité possible juste
pour conclure il va y avoir
effectivement ces assemblées générales
de l'onu jean françois di meglio est ce
que la chine risque tout de même d'être
mis en difficulté parce que ce rapport
sort littéralement une semaine avant
il y aura certainement il y aura
certainement un débat autour de ce
rapport on pourra pas l'éviter ce qui
est certain c'est qu'une assemblée
générale c'est quelque chose de très
complexe vous avez l'assemblée générale
ce qui est visible vous pouvez avoir une
prise de position effectivement on se
souvient de prises de position française
à l'assemblée générale il y aura
beaucoup de très beau monde à cette
assemblée générale comme vous le savez
néanmoins ce qui se passe aussi en
coulisses va être extrêmement important
et il est clair que la tentative je
dirais de renversement de majorité de
l'onu par la chine est en route est-ce
qu'elle aboutira est-ce que
techniquement on peut aller jusqu'à
changer le cours d'une assemblée
générale je crois que c'est très
difficile il est clair que l'onu comme
vous le disiez
s'est donné les moyens d'être entendu
sur des sujets où on avait tendance ces
temps ci a considéré que l'onu était un
autre machin
intéresse appelle pékin à suivre les
recommandations du rapport voilà donc il
va y avoir certains fait beaucoup rire
les gens intéressants ça vous fait rire
mais l'onu non c'est parce que je pense
que l'onu il ya eu des votes dans le
passé qui remonteraient effectivement
que nous disait tout à l'heure mauvoisin
qu'aucun pays arabe effectivement deux
pays des publications régionales n'a
soutenu finalement les condamnations
demandés contre la chine ce qui fait
qu'il ya eu des votes je crois qu'il ya
une quarantaine de pays qui ont conduit
la chine et quand il ya eu un vote pour
chanter venir la chine sur le même
problème il ya eu à peu près 70 à 80
donc on est quand même le rapport de
force ce n'est pas la chine qui va
renverser le rapport de force est elle
venue sur ce territoire des champions je
doute fort qu'on d une majorité à
l'intérieur de l'onu si vous voulez pour
appuyer ce rapport est d'accord il
européenne devra s'investir plus souvent
c'est sur cette question à l'internement
et démocratie européenne il mais qu'est
ce que vous voulez où vous prenez
vraiment des mesures draconiennes par
exemple oui limiter les importations de
chine ou bien vous faites vous parler et
vous fait des petites mesures des
mesurettes mais je vois pas bien même
l'europe même les états unis furent
beaucoup plus que ça il nous reste 5
minutes donc j'ai un peu plus de temps
que prévu
d'ignorer anne est ce que l'onu devrait
diligenter une enquête maintenant c'est
ce que
c'est ce que qu'on recommande aussi
qu'on demande mais l'anc est de toute
façon en fait comme nous avons vu en mai
dernier avec la visite guidée de michel
vachon et par la chine qui à faire vous
la critique aujourd'hui alors qu'elle
est quand même à l'origine de ce rapport
au rapport à aller comment elle a été le
rapport rien été a été rédigée depuis
plus d'un an et que elle elle devait
effectuer justement une enquête ce
qu'elle n'a pas fait elle a effectué une
visite et enfin sa visite guidée est là
elle a refusé de rencontrer des
commandes les rescapés de camps donc une
enquête de l'onu pour vous c'est inutile
sinon c'est pas une étude qu'il vient
sur 1100 sera pas rien été puisque en
fait on a vu on a espéré que ce soit une
enquête cependant fait au départ ça
allait être une enquête ensuite ça
partait en fait de l'ue vise en visite
visite guidée et donc la chine exerce
une pression énorme si la raison pour
laquelle effectivement ce rapport a
retardé plus d'un an également donc tant
que la shinra ce qu'on a ce pouvoir de
pression sur le monde sur l'onu et que
les démocraties dites démocratie ne fait
rien alors qu'on va les démocraties
quand il quand elles veulent elles
peuvent comme comme on a vu dans le cas
de l'ukraine et de la russie avait une
proposition totale entre la chine et les
états unis on peut le dire jean françois
di meglio même dans ce dossier chinois
après tout bon job hayden a mis en avant
les valeurs démocratiques face à la
chine non puisque ce qu'on est en train
de dire ce qu alain à souligner c'est
que on ne peut pas débrancher les fils
de l'interdépendance mondiale du jour au
lendemain effectivement à chaque moment
la question qui se pose c'est est-ce que
ce geste va être les prémices de
débranchement de
l'interconnexion mondiale donc ça
effectivement personne aujourd'hui n'est
prêt
à aller jusque là en revanche ce que
ceux ci soulignent c'est une question
plus générale dans le multilatéralisme
sait l'importance pour la chine de sa
souveraineté est effectivement un
certain nombre de pays pourrait en
prendre de la graine une enquête de
l'onu seraient perçues par la chine
d'une certaine façon comme une atteinte
à son intégrité à sa souveraineté de la
même façon qu'un certain nombre
d'observateurs extérieurs qui irait
vérifier les émissions de carbone de une
pourrait être aussi considérés comme des
ingérences dans ce que fait le film donc
ma période mais n'a rien à cacher elle
peut y laisser rentrer alors nous
n'avons pas la même conception de la
souveraineté et je pense qu'il ya un
vrai débat là dessus le multilatéralisme
peut aller avec des souverainetés qui
s'entendent peut-être pas avec la
conception chinoise si nous reste une ou
deux minutes je voudrais quand même
terminé peut-être sur une note un peu
plus optimiste
les choses sont claires pour le prochain
congrès qui démarre le 16 octobre si
j'ai une ping va être reconduit et il
aura une équipe à sa mesure à son choix
mais c'est pas forcément éternelle on ne
sait pas ce qui se passe à l'intérieur
du parti communiste chinois
mais moi ça ne m'étonnerait pas trop que
y est quand même une contestation de la
politique de xi jinping sur le plan
idéologique sur le plan
économique ça va mal a quand même en
chine chômage maintenant il ya une sorte
de contrat social qui est rompu en chine
et on peut demander un jour des comptes
assez jean ping ça n'est pas inévitable
le parti communiste en soi a une
histoire est ce ce et bouge d'une
certaine manière on l'avait vu même avec
mao qui avait été mis à l'écart après le
grand bond en avant ça peut ça peut se
produire
à des expériences oui sur les et ça peut
avoir des conséquences sur les ouigours
pas nécessairement et parce que le
successeur de jean ping s'est jamais
rien à un peu continuer enfin c'est pas
obligatoire oui mot de la fin une minute
je répète encore une fois qui en fait un
commentaire il ya il ya un peuple est en
train d'être a dit qu'il ya génocide en
cours depuis cinq ans et que les
démocraties n'est fait en ne faisant
rien concrètement et que et l'argent et
l'économie ils sont mises sont vous
appelez vous avez fait des sanctions en
fête européenne et que ces distinctions
mais aussi enfin il faut que la chine
rendre compte devant une cour
internationale
merci beaucoup d'avoir avec nous il n'y
aurait à merci beaucoup jean françois di
meglio merci jean paul chang merci alain
de chalvron merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivis et vous restez avec nous
sur france 24
[Musique]